hello everyone thank you so much for
coming to my talk my name is Joe and if
you can't tell from my accent I'm from
the UK in London not Australia or
Ireland as some of the people here have
been guessing from my accent I am a
developer advocate which means that I
get to do fun things like talk to all of
you and make silly things on the
internet to talk about and some of the
things that I've made recently include a
virtual reality game based on an xkcd
comic does anybody remember this one the
emoji sports so I decided to make
hedgehog curling which is the one in the
top right hand corner there so this is
my VR Hedgehog curling game on the left
and then on the right is a very
important app called biscuit tinder
which is a progressive web app that
allows you to rate your favorite
biscuits and I also have something to
confess I'm a bit of a notification
addict
I love getting that little reminder that
someone out in the world is thinking
about me and not only that but I get
kind of anxious like actual genuine like
sweaty withdrawal if I'm away from the
internet for too long if I don't have an
internet connection and in fact visiting
the states has been really good for me
because not only am I now missing all
the tweets in my feed because I'm in the
wrong timezone but also I can't afford
the roaming data so every time I leave
the hotel and cut off like cold turkey
but the story that I'm here to tell you
about is basically my attempt at
enabling my own addiction at a time when
I knew when I wouldn't be able to
constantly check my phone my wedding day
so let's begin at the beginning of this
story and our story begins at an EMF
camp long long ago now EMF camp if
you've not heard of it before for want
of a better description
it's like Glastonbury Festival for nerds
so imagine a huge field a bunch of nerds
all bring their tents they bring their
hacking projects with them
to this field in the middle of the UK
and there's electronics there's
computing those robotics there's
knitting you name it bring it to the
camp pack on it give talks party and
it's super fun and at one of these camps
somebody brought along a giant
inflatable bunny rabbit
and when I say giant I mean this thing
was three meters tall and it had some
LEDs in it and it had its own Twitter
account and you could tweet a color to
it and it would change to that color and
I really loved this idea changing the
way that we interact with tweets really
kind of resonated with me you know when
we tweet we broadcast a view that we're
hoping that people are going to read
that they're gonna interact with and
respond to but the inflatable bunny kind
of took this idea from the virtual world
to the physical world and it changes the
way those interactions happen I started
wondering what it would be like if we
could have a thing in our own physical
environment that our friends and our
loved ones could change just to say that
they're thinking about us no words no
message no real content just the change
of colors you could delight or surprise
someone from half the world away and so
a scenario kind of like this iconic
scene from Sleeping Beauty played out in
my head where two people could be
warring to change the color of the
rabbit from around the world and then I
thought what if the LEDs in the rabbit
were in something wearable what if they
were in a dress like this what if they
were in my wedding dress my friends and
everyone from around the world will be
able to change the color of the dress
and it would be like having their
thoughts and well-wishes right there
with me while I was walking down the
aisle
so here began my quest to make a
tweetable light-up wedding dress but my
quest almost instantly hit a brick wall
I was really excited about the idea but
I had genuinely no idea where to start
now I studied electronic engineering at
uni which should mean I know all about
this stuff and I'm a web developer so
using the Twitter API should be a walk
in the park
I spend a lot of my time battling this
thing called impostor syndrome which is
the idea that everyone around you knows
more than you or that everyone else
knows everything and that one day you're
going to slip up and everyone will
realize that you don't know what you're
doing that you don't belong that you're
a fraud has anyone else ever felt like
this that's a lot of hands and it's
pretty prevalent with people who work in
the tech industry we spend all our time
surrounded by these brilliant
intelligent people and we have a
tendency to compare ourselves with them
and to do so unfavorably so I was kind
of afraid to ask for help because I felt
like it would be giving away the fact
that I didn't know what I was doing not
only that but I also suffer from anxiety
related to perfectionism and this
sometimes stops me from getting started
on projects I'm sure a lot of you have
felt this as well it's the idea that
you're afraid of getting started on a
project in case you mess up or because
you can't pick the exact perfect way to
get started
so you just put it off and you
procrastinate and you get this sort of
per decision paralysis that makes it
difficult to even get started so I found
it tough to even get my idea of the
ground and I wasn't sure where to start
I was afraid to ask people directly for
help
incidentally I would like to make a call
back here to both Tilda's talk yesterday
and lares talk today and also blame
capitalism for many of the problems
associated with both impostor syndrome
and perfectionism but back to the story
I knew I needed some lights and I needed
some sort of microcontroller board and I
needed some way to control what color
the lights would turn I'd need some kind
of Wi-Fi connection and a battery that
is small enough that I could secret it
away somewhere on my person so I did
what I always do when I'm stuck board or
procrastinating and I went on Twitter
you may have noticed that I'm a little
bit addicted to Twitter but I needed a
starting point or I'd procrastinate
forever so I asked for advice from a
general populace which is much easier
than us
being a person individually what they
would use if they were building such a
project and the advice that I received
it was kind of amazing you might
actually recognize some of the people in
this room from this Twitter stream a lot
of advice but it was amazing like I
cannot thank everyone enough and they
learn a lot so it the first thing like
that I learnt is that there is a board
called an Adafruit further hazhar and it
measures approximately five centimeters
by two centimeters and it weighs about
six grams which is great there's hardly
anything that's very easy to sew into a
dress it also has Wi-Fi which means that
I'll be able to get the data from
Twitter to the lights and it has a USB
connector so RBO to upload easily from
my computer when I've written the code
and I'll also be able to use a USB
battery like this to power it and it
costs about twenty dollars which was
well within my budget so I was pretty
happy with that
there we go and I also discovered that
Adafruit also make these little
individually programmable LEDs they call
them pixels and they're lightweight and
tiny and they've got little interfaces
around the side for a sewing in
conductive thread or for soldering if
you'd prefer that and they've also got
some really great documentation and a
whole load of example code they also
cost about I think it's about $2 each or
maybe a dollar fifty each and I needed
about 100 of them for the dress which is
just way out of my budget so what did I
end up actually buying well I bought the
huzzah and then after searching around
Aliexpress and Amazon and eBay
I found these Chinese knockoff versions
of the Adafruit neopixels
and they were about twenty-five dollars
for a hundred and also the board was
white which was a plus cause it was
going in a white dress the solder points
on the back are so teeny tiny I'll show
you a close-up of them later and they
don't have any holes for sewing but
honestly I am really terrible at sewing
so I don't know who
I was kidding thinking I was going to
sew these in I was always going to glue
them in I also bought a soldering iron
and all the stuff that goes with it so
some solder a solder sucker and as I
said my initial plan I thought that
maybe I would sew the LEDs in and
someone on the Twitter thread had
mentioned the stuff called conductive
thread which you can use to connect up
the LEDs but also from the thread that I
discovered that actually the impedance
of the thread is very high so if you
want a hundred LEDs that's not really
the thing to use and also if you're
going to be moving around in it a lot
the thread isn't great for the
connection and I am a swing dance
teacher so I was going to be moving
around a lot in the dress so I decided
to go through this single core copper
wire instead which is really nice and
easy to solder because you don't get the
frayed ends and then my plan was to make
an underskirt nice circle skirt out of
this tulle netting and then to hot glue
the lighting to it and to connect them
up with the copper wire so now I had all
of the gear but still very little idea
of what actually to do with it so again
I leant on the community for some help
and I attended a hackathon and there
were loads of lovely people there who
helped me to get started who sent me up
with the idea the Arduino IDE and
pointed me in the right direction for
getting started with working with the
lights so what did I do
first of all I think not seen it before
the thing that you're going to want to
use to write code for the Adafruit
feather hazhar is the Arduino IDE and
the ID comes with a whole bunch of
libraries and example code that can get
you up and running instantly if this is
your first ever project so you'll need
to install the package that will make
your code work with the board that
you've bought so in my case this is the
package for the hazhar and then once
you've done that install the library for
the Adafruit neopixels from the library
manager that comes with the IDE and the
brilliant thing about this is once
you've done that
you've got a whole load of just snippets
of example code that you can use with
the neopixels so for example it comes
with something called the strand test
which is brilliant for testing when you
have a string of RGB LEDs it cycles
through every single color so you can
make sure that you've connected all your
LEDs up correctly so the next thing that
I needed to do is connect up some LEDs
[Music]
so these are the LEDs that I bought you
can see the back so there's helpful
markings so you can see which one is the
power which one is the data and which
one is the ground and you need to solder
them together like this so you make sure
that they're all pointing in the right
direction important thing to note here
to remember for later or pointing in the
right direction but they have helpful
arrows on them and they're all labeled
so you can get them all chained up
facing in the right direction
next I connected the LEDs up to the
board so the power line is going into
the USB pin because I'm using my USB
batteries the data line goes to pin 4 on
the board and ground goes to ground and
the final thing to do is to upload my
strand test to the board connect up the
battery and voila it kind of worked so
now I've got my board set up I know that
the lights are working but what's next
well before I move on to explain what I
did next I want to talk a little bit
about what these LEDs are actually doing
and how they work so what are RGB LEDs
first of all remember when you're in
school and you mix paints together and
you are told that there are three
primary colors your red yellow and blue
and you might have been given a color
mixing chart that looks something like
this so red and yellow is orange red and
blue is purple these are things that we
all know you mix all three of them
together and you get this like [ __ ]
brownie black color so that's paint but
with light is slightly different so
instead of red and yellow and blue we
have red and green and blue and they
combine
like this it's a red and blue still make
purple but red and green now make yellow
and green and blue now make cyan and we
combine all of the colors to make white
so why does this matter
well the RGB in RGB LED stands for red
green blue and inside each LED is a
little tiny red green and blue light and
because the human eyes aren't that great
and the LEDs are actually very close to
each other we see all these colors
combined as one so this is a very very
close up of our little tiny individual
pixels and so we can send a value to
each of these three lights to tell it
how bright to shine exactly like we
would if we were setting a color using
RGB in CSS so we use numbers between
naught and 255 not being completely
turned off 255 being completely turned
on and we can give each LED a number
between these to create many many many
different colors so for example if I
sent color to 5500 that would be full
brightness in red no blue and no green
what color would it shine yeah and 255 0
255 would be full-on in red
no green and full-on in blue what color
would that give us magenta yeah and
that's great for us we've all written
CSS we can understand what is happening
here but I was guessing that most of the
people who were coming to my wedding
wouldn't know these 3 values they would
want to tweet a color name to my Twitter
account so I needed a way that I could
get those color names and then convert
them to their RGB values and then web
gives us a whole load of color names so
let's take a look at some of them now so
we've got red green and blue those are
fairly obvious we've got power cool they
start to get a little bit whimsical so
you can have like chocolate or tomato
and then they get quite curious so peach
puff and ghost white and when I said we
got there mint cream
so I wanted people to be able to tweet
any of these any of the HTML color names
to my Twitter account and then I would
have to get the text of what they sent
and converted so in order to get the
text the first thing I needed to do is
create a Twitter account then I needed
to write some code that was going to
convert the tweets from the HTML color
name to the RGB get that RGB value from
the internet to the board make the board
send the right color to the lights and
that should be it so setting up a
Twitter account fairly self-explanatory
once that's done in order to get access
to the Twitter API you go to developer
Twitter comm you can create an app you
have to fill in a whole long form about
what your app is and what you're going
to do is it Twitter are really clamping
down on developers making Twitter like
experiences these days so you have to
describe what your app is going to do
they don't want you to just show a feed
but once you've filled in the form and
it's been accepted then you have an app
which means that you have an API key
which is what you're going to need when
you use the Twitter API now I did this
in two different ways
depending on what your favorite language
is there's a whole bunch of different
ways that you can access the Twitter API
and my original method I used OAuth in
PHP mostly because I found a video on
YouTube that was like this is how you do
it right this and I basically just typed
out exactly what they said in the video
I shoved it up onto my hosting and it
was great I could get my Twitter
mentions like he get the mentions at the
Twitter account at Joe's dress and it
was working for about five days and then
and then it wasn't working and I'm not a
sysadmin and I'm not a back-end
developer and when my code started
giving me server errors instead of
giving me my Twitter mentions I had
literally no idea what happened
so I scrapped it all and started again
in the language that I do actually know
and I'm more comfortable with which was
JavaScript so this time I used node and
an NPM package called twit which is
really great it gives you a whole bunch
of request options for working with the
Twitter API so you can do things like
get your
or timeline or you can just get mentions
you can post the status you can do a
search and with so with the search
method I was able to get any text that
mentioned at Joe's dress if you want to
see my code it's on that glint glitch
link there I'm not going to walk through
it because it's basically just the twit
package with at Joe's dress in it and
you can look that up in your own time
but if you do want to take a look at it
it's right there so the first thing that
they had to do was take the text from
dimensions and search through it for any
RGB color values and there may well be a
better way to do this I'm sure some of
you can think of a better way right now
but this is how I did it I created an
array that contained all of the HTML
colors that exist which I got from this
link here HTML color codes comm / color
names and there are a lots of them
and each color name was the key to a set
of three numbers which is the RGB values
I then got the content of the tweet
using the Twitter package and I'd loop
through this array checking whether or
not it contained any of the keys so for
example if I got a tweet that said at
Joe's dress show me a chartreuse my code
would go through and say okay does this
text contain Alice blue now does it
contain antique white no does it contain
aqua no and we go through and through
and through until we get to chartreuse
and it says yes that the corresponding
RGB value is one two seven two five five
zero and it will return that I hosted my
code up on Heroku which is currently at
this link here let's see can we actually
it's my mouse on the spring
[Music]
see if I can actually because Heroku I'm
only using the free service it times out
because my dress is polling every 10
seconds and I've currently got two
boards in there so who wrote who keeps
timing me out let's see if it's backup
[Music]
ray so at the moment it looks like the
dress is supposed to be blue so if I
plug it back in now that we no longer
timed out let's see if it eventually
ties back to blue okay so my experience
with coding for microcontrollers was
basically nothing at the point where I
decided to do this dress project and I
took very heavy inspiration read copied
and pasted from the example code that
came with the IDE I knew I needed to get
to connect the board to a Wi-Fi
connection I knew I needed to send the
get request to the Heroku URL that I
just put up there and then I needed to
take that RGB value that I got from that
get request and send it to the LEDs and
the Arduino IDE comes with each of these
bits of code that I needed so it comes
if you go to file in example there's an
example to connect to Wi-Fi there's an
example descent the get request and
there's an example to send a color to a
pixel which is basically exactly what I
needed and when I was learning front-end
development I learned like copying other
people's websites and deleting bits
until I worked out what was going on and
so I used the same approach for this
project no need to rewrite code that's
already been written and the Arduino IDE
provides us with a monitor that you can
print to so that you can do the same
kind of thing that you would if you're
debugging your JavaScript code with a
console log so you can see what's
happening on the board and
as with many projects it wasn't as
smooth sailing as I would have liked it
to be so not only did the failure of my
API for reasons unknown happen but there
are a whole bunch of issues that
happened just because I didn't really
know enough about what I was doing so
first of all those knockoff pixels that
I bought I was sending my RGB value to
them and when I was telling them to turn
blue they turned green and when I was
telling them to turn green they turned
blue but when I told them to turn red
they were red and it took me an
embarrassingly long time to work out
that these knockoff RGB LEDs went RGB
LEDs they were RBG LEDs or brg yeah
that's one so I had to send the numbers
in a different order turns out those
neopixels are expensive for a reason I
also discovered when I made mark two of
the dress and I bought a different type
of LED every time I sent a color to it
every fourth LED was changing to
different colors so it'd be like pink
pink pink yellow pink pink pink yellow
what is going on here turns out you can
also get RGB W LEDs they take a false
value for the brightness both of these
changes were one character fixes that
took me about two days each to find but
that was the software written and the
hardware was tested so now it was time
to put it all together there we go and
have you heard of the saying measure
twice cut once I'm much more of a
measure never cut forever kind of a girl
and I can tell you that that is an
incredibly frustrating way to be
seriously everyone if you can measure
twice cut once
so the first mistake that I made was I
assumed that I knew how to make a circle
skirt you know there's beautiful swing
skirts that do the swooshing when you 12
so the theory with them is that you take
a piece of fabric you follow
into quarters you cut an arc around one
edge and you cut another one in the
middle that should be a quarter of your
waistline in length
guess who cut the hole in the middle way
too big and had to sew darts into it to
make it smaller the next mistake that I
made I got really overexcited once I've
made the circle skirt and I hot-glued
all my LEDs into the fabric because I
didn't want the layout of the lights to
be too even I wanted it to sort of look
like a starry sky so I thought it would
be fine if I just glued them all in and
then connected them up but guess what I
didn't consider what did I mention
earlier the direction that all the LEDs
were facing oh the fact that each of
them needs three wires to connect them
and now they were all random distances
apart so every single distance I had to
measure three wires and cut them for
exactly the right length oh the one
lucky break that I had here was that as
soon as you hold a soldering iron to the
solder points on the back it melted the
hot glue and I was able to just turn the
led around to face it in that direction
yeah I'm an idiot
so it took about 12 hours of
back-breaking very dull soldering work
to get all of the lights connected
together and the other problem with
soldering when your lights are already
connected into the netting is that a
soldering iron goes through netting like
a hot knife through butter or like a
soldering iron through button you might
say so I've burnt so many holes in this
thing it's great that it goes underneath
the dress I discovered since putting
this together that you can buy presort
of strings of RGB LEDs and for God's
sake if you're making something like
this buy those
this is the most fiddly back-breaking
thing I've ever done in my life but it
did look really pretty when I plucked it
all in and I ran my strand test on it
but then guess what happened as soon as
I tried wearing it and walking around
the house a whole bunch of the solder
points instantly snapped and I had to go
back and resold it the whole thing and
then after more advice from the internet
hot glued the back of all of the LEDs to
give a little bit of strength to those
solder points so the final challenge
that I had was putting this skirt into
my actual wedding dress and that
involved sewing which I hate so the
dress had lots of layers of netting and
a satin underskirt and I wanted the LED
to sit on top of the satin and the skirt
but under the layers of netting so that
I got a nice dispersed effect from the
LEDs if I was able to sew properly
either done a beautiful job of this
instead I just did tacking stitch all
the way around the top and assume that
no one is ever gonna look and finally I
needed a way first of all I needed
somewhere to hide the battery and
secondly I needed a way for the battery
to get from basically my underwear to
the dress which is on top now of the
satin underskirt so I bought these
stunningly beautiful white cycling
shorts which who knew they made white
cycling shorts which have a nice little
pocket in them so I could keep the LED
and keep the battery in there and I had
to cut a hole into my dress and when you
just spent hundreds of dollars on a
dress cutting a hole into it is
terrifying
so yeah that's me with the shorts if I
was again able to sew I'd have done a
beautiful buttonhole stitch around the
hole I can't so I just dropped a load of
I was super glue on it and it was ready
to go
and this is the only picture / gif that
I have of it because guess what I got
into the taxi on the way to the wedding
and one of the solder points snapped and
no one ever saw it but but the thing is
that it didn't really matter because I
learn a load of stuff and I made a thing
that I was really proud of and I was
able to take it home and iterate on it
and take all the stuff that I'd learnt
and make it better I say better this
isn't working
so when you embark on a new project
you're going to make mistakes you're
gonna do things that occasionally make
people raise an eyebrow but that's okay
if that's the way you work allow
yourself to make mistakes and then
you're gonna learn how to do it better
you're never going to get it exactly
right the first time around I don't know
how many of you have ever heard of the
phrase perfect is the enemy of great if
you're aiming for perfection you cannot
help but set yourself up to fail
most people don't achieve perfection and
they certainly don't achieve it the
first time around if you're aiming for
that you're never going to actually
achieve because you'll never reach it
just start just make something and
you'll end up with something great if
you need to try things out and see what
happens do that if you need to plan
everything out before you get it started
and plan everything to the last detail
then let yourself do that find the way
that you work best and understand it and
allow yourself to work in that way when
I try and force myself to like plan and
measure everything I just spent forever
procrastinating because I hate that I
like to just dive in with the scissors
and see what happens
[Music]
and one of the things that I've learnt
is that even though asking for help this
feels really embarrassing and it feels
like you're admitting that you don't
know something asking for help is a
brilliant way not only to learn what
you're doing but also to meet awesome
members of our community if I hadn't put
that original tweet out I'd have known
Stephanie who is now a really lovely
friend and also completely and utterly
saved my ass at least twice a day once
by lending me a soldering iron and
secondly by setting me up with a hot
spot so I would like to just give her a
little tiny round of applause thing and
our tech community is full of so many
really lovely people who are willing to
help and you know also some opinionated
people who just like the sound of their
own voices but don't be afraid to reach
out to people the worse that they'll do
is that they tell you that they don't
have time to help you and the best that
they'll do is help you or point you
towards somebody else who can help you
and if you do have expertise of your own
please offer help to others attend
hackathons work with beginners try and
mentoring or attending a code club and
even just answering questions on Twitter
is just so brilliant and helpful and I
would never have made this non-working
dress if it's definitely hadn't answered
my questions on Twitter and if you're
not an expert getting involved in
helping people out with their projects
is also a really brilliant way to learn
stuff so thank you so much for coming
and listening to me I think I have time
for questions yeah loads of time
excellent
does anyone have any questions
[Applause]
green t-shirt so my next project which I
have actually already agreed to give a
talk on and haven't built yet
it's a Christmas jumper so I hope to get
it done before Christmas and I've got a
million different ideas for what I'm
gonna do I went to see Katy Perry live
recently and she had a LED display bra
basically that was showing the lyrics to
all of her songs and I was thinking like
I could have like ho ho ho cross my
chest I don't know we'll see what
happens there any more questions so this
the LEDs that I've actually got in here
are mark 2 and mark 3 of the dress
because mark 1 died to death the one
where I soldered it all individually
like not that so I then discovered I
don't know if you can see them from here
these ribbon LEDs they come on a strip
they're great but quite temperamental
I'd like for some reason switch off
after a certain amount of time I don't
really know what's going on there so
then I tried mark 3 which is these ones
which I thought might be a little hard
yeah they're also a bit larger so
they're a bit brighter but it turns out
that because the solder points are going
up into the board like that and it's
wearable you get a lot of work hardening
and they snap really badly
so now I've discovered you can get ones
like this they have a plastic coating
over them they're meant to be waterproof
outdoor lights which I originally didn't
go with because I thought they'd be too
heavy for a dress but with more netting
I reckon you can lift them up or with
more netting you would just disperse the
light better so that's mark for the
dress the other thing that I would like
to do is maybe try a different kind of
battery
these just don't last very long I've
heard lithium-ion batteries may be
better but also the folding exploding
problem for wearables so I don't know
we'll see what happens they're more
planning I guess yeah does that answer
your question yeah I I don't know
anything about those but I have seen
them before like in t-shirts and things
so you can basically have your sound
bars as the music is playing like that
would be super fun to play with and
you'd need some sort of microphone in
your clothing so that they could hear
the music or yeah something like that
yeah they would be really fun to play
with that was for people who didn't hear
it have you heard of LEDs that react to
music yep it was a lot of work and
honestly it was about a year so if you
look at the date of that first tweet I
was like I've got this harebrained idea
sorry the question was like basically I
guess how did you how did I keep going
through being an idiot
yeah it it took me about a year so I sat
on the idea of after I did that original
tweet i sat there going like oh maybe
you know I could do this and I could do
that and
then and then the date started getting
closer that's like oh okay you have to
actually build something now if you're
gonna do this plus I was trying to keep
it a secret from my husband
and I managed to solder that whole thing
together in the kitchen for 12 hours
without him noticing which it goes to
show how observant he is um but I guess
it's it's another case of the whole like
once you get started it's you're kind of
invested in it so you're like well you
know I've spent the money on the LEDs
now and I've started this stupid project
I may as well get it out there plus my
notification addiction kind of drives me
to make stupid things so that more
people click to like on them I guess
yeah like just keep going because
otherwise you don't have anything at the
end of it yes I did I did and I yeah I'm
not sure it could be because because I
don't have the arduino ide on this
computer i can't check what's going on
on the board at the moment so it could
be that my Wi-Fi is down it could be
that my power for some reason isn't
working it could be that the LEDs are
shorted it could be a whole load of
different things that are stopping it
from working at the moment and I'm I
have a bit of a curse with this dress in
demos it was literally working an hour
ago in my hotel room it's just one of
those things where you're like oh come
on but yes I did the tweets were working
at Joe's dress is the Twitter account I
will try and get it working again and
like maybe have it out in the hallway or
something and you can come in to eat at
it yep from Stephanie
um I really like rainbows and sparkly
things so for me more rainbows and more
sparkly things it's always better so
that's quite a driving passion for me
and I saw Stephanie show her umbrella
and cascade dress at a talk a while ago
and just was like ah you can wear
rainbows and sparkly things and you know
that was it for me now I want everything
to be lighting up okay shall we call it
thank you so much everybody for coming
[Applause]